what's the most challenging part of
being married yes oh that's hard that's
challenging aspect of my of your
marriage I think that
outside influences in your relationship
so family you know your kids as they
become adult kids all of those
Transitions and then I think
um transitioning through life at the
same rate you know we all evolve and so
you know if you're evolving at a
different rate I think that's also uh
that's also really hard
um but you know it's a I think you just
have to have a mentality that you're
just putting your shoulder into it it's
like I don't really care what goes wrong
I mean I do that shouldn't shouldn't say
that but you have to just be willing to
put a shoulder into it and just like do
hard things
yeah no I definitely I think like that's
a really good question that he asked
because I think
like people don't are not really
listening to the opinions of people who
are successful as in in relationships
and stuff like that because I would see
you as successful and because you're
married you've done it for a long time
you've raised children etc etc
successful children and stuff like that
so like obviously you're I'm gonna
listen if I if I'm in a situation where
like okay I'm thinking about marriage
and you know I'm taking it seriously and
I want to know you know what the
pitfalls are and stuff like I'm gonna
ask you but I think a lot of modern
women are asking single women or
unsuccessful women their opinions about
about I have a battery I have a better
answer actually
um it's when your kids are in pain and
you don't react to it the same because
you're both very invested in your kids
you love your kids right and so when
they are struggling you don't solve the
problem in the same way and you know if
it's like I want to you know burn
somebody's eyes out if they hurt my kid
and if we both have that opinion and
then we feel like we're both doing it
wrong that's probably the hardest thing
oh yeah
that's interesting do you would you
agree that a lot of times women are
taking their cues from maybe a lot of
other single women who are women that
are not in any better situation than
they are and then they're going to them
asking their opinion and these are the
type of people that will be you know
giving you the advice oh yeah treat your
man like they're your coaches do you
know how many coaches on the internet
trying like they want you to pay they're
gonna give you the success of
relationship and everything but
themselves have never achieved anything
yet
yeah well what like so so do you think a
lot more than women they're going to the
wrong sources was there do you think
okay let me go like this do you think a
lot of times women are lying to women
when in terms of how to be successful in
dating and stuff like that in
relationships do you think women lie to
women a lot because I personally do yeah
100 yes yes it's because women they have
a kind of bitter competition sometimes
man doesn't but women they have this
competition like oh my husband he gave
me this you know well and I think it's a
self-absorbed perspective so you know
like it isn't just modern women it's all
women if they're if you're a traditional
woman and you've decided your heads out
you're gonna go look for the right
advice to convince yourself that it's
time to leave and that that's better for
my family it's better for me
I think that's women in general I don't
think it's Unique to to the type of
woman yeah I think that's what we do we
go look for validation for what our
perspective is
you don't have to look for it what's the
worst advice you ever got from a single
woman about your marriage
I mean you know there's always a leave
that's always yeah you feel like did
single women ever encourage you of
course I mean you know I made a habit as
much as I could of not complaining out
outside of my marriage I mean obviously
you do but I would say that you know
people want you people have a desire for
likeness so I want you to want what I
want right I'm sitting here trying to
convince you both of you like please
don't do what you're doing come do what
I'm doing because I think it's better
that's what women do we all do it and so
I think that when you go to get advice
you should only go to get advice from
people that you want to Aspire to be
like not you know not the opposite
absolutely absolutely
all right this has been awesome we got
Lee Young for hitting up the cash out
appreciate that my bro big up to
um
all right why do women
usually terminate marriages
what is the reason behind that why do we
mean Instagram
mom
why do you think women usually terminate
marriages
I mean it's complicated I think it's
boring so we were talking about you were
talking about
um that it's hard for both men and women
in marriages I think what is hard for
men they're big rocks right I have to
protect I have to provide for my family
I mean these are really big things and
women and I can say that I'm in this
group it's like you feel like you're
shoveling pebbles for the rest of your
[__] life and it's like you empty the
sink and it's full again and you empty
the dishwasher and it's full again and
you change the diaper and it's full
again and it's just like this it's like
I'm dating myself but it's like Laverne
and Shirley and they had like the candy
on the on the conveyor belt and it
wouldn't stop coming and I think that's
what women that's what's hard for women
it's like that that is the hard part and
then you want the exciting stuff right
well you don't feel you know and then if
you're you know my husband isn't good at
saying like go honey thanks for changing
the diaper like that's I mean most
people don't do that because in its in
that small sector changing a diaper
doesn't you know it's nothing it's
nothing in the grand scheme of things
you're going to go risk your life and
I'm complaining about a diaper you know
that seems like lame except for it's
that you've just done 20 of those today
you've given five kids a bath you've
done homework with all of them you've
gone to basketball games soccer games
you got the car wash you had to go meet
with the insurance guy you know by the
way one of the kids broke a window so
you called it and so like you just feel
like you're like oh my God I can't you
know I can't come up for air and then
you know he comes home from work and is
like ah today was a shitty day and
you're like oh don't even get on me you
know and so I think that what happens is
is that it's that that's lack of being
fulfilled and so one day you realize
you've looked like a wreck for 10 years
and you're like wait I don't want to do
this anymore and so I think that's what
like the the thought process is behind
it and I'm not justifying it but I'm
saying I've seen it over and over again
um and in this world that we're in so
many you know moms including me I had a
career I had a big career I spent a lot
of time on the road Hannah knows I
traveled a lot it was really really
really hard I have tenacity I have a
work ethic that's probably been a fault
but there's a world full of people that
don't have that and so it's kind of an
unsustainable reality the women in the
world are you know they want to have
these big careers they want to have you
know maybe they don't want to have
families anymore but they want to have
all these things and it's unsustainable
and so I think that's when they're like
check mark I'm out I'm just gonna go get
rid of the easy button and the Easy
Button happens to be the the husband and
the kids
wow that's that's crazy I've never like
I've never heard it like that and it
makes I kind of see I'm kind of
understanding where
women come from where they're coming
from from your life from what you've
just said like so like you know if
you've been doing this for like 10 years
you know you've had like multiple kids
blah blah blah like that makes sense I
can I can understand I'm not saying it's
right or wrong but I can understand it
because
you know life it can be monotonous I
understand why do you why do you think
that women will think the grass is
greener on the other side
because I think the perspective that
they surround themselves by gives them
that perspective and you know when
you're in the throes of it like for me
again like my only my own perspective
it's not anybody else's but you know we
had an au pair so we had somebody that
lived in our house and helped take care
of our kids
we did that because you know my husband
was vacant he a lot of times he was gone
many many hours working crazy hours and
so you know that was the best type of
child care for our for our family
regardless of that
when I got home at night she was off
duty so here I am working all day long
doing my job and then I get home and I
work until you know I go to bed and then
you know the kids get up at night you
get up with them and I wouldn't want him
to get up with him I want to do that but
the point on all of it is just to say
that it becomes like a treadmill you
feel like you can't press the stop
button on and so you got to give
something and you've built your career
it's about you it's about you know it's
it's by you for you buy you for you and
suddenly you're like check mark I'm out
I can't do all of these things so I'm
not going to give up the one thing
that's for myself
crazy what about because that again I
understand what you're saying but I
think like a lot of times when we see
these examples of women just checking
out of their marriages and stuff A lot
of times it's not that situation a lot
of times it'll be like maybe they've
been with the guy one year two year
three year out one kid out I think they
married I think they married the
Instagram photos
they wanted to get married just to have
the
the image I mean I know a couple of
marriages that was like I agree they did
they just got married for the white
dress and the children
for the Instagram photo yeah what was he
gonna what did you think I completely
agree with her I think now Family
marriages Instagram picture when you go
to like Europe when you travel as well
you don't care about knowing the place
more
you're more concerned about the pictures
you're gonna be posting on Instagram so
do you think a lot a lot of times when
because obviously I think men do want to
get married but it's more times this
woman will be pushing for it like let's
get married let's have a kid let's have
it because the timeline in it like you
know biological clock etc etc so
like with that being said
do you feel like
I've lost my fort
I was trying to get it I just lost my
fault but it's crazy though like you
know like women just kind of want that
party and it's like they don't really
care about the guy that much it's like
they care about the whole Fiasco the
whole like I want to be the center of
attention on my way
and I want my bridesmaids to be just
nice but not nicer than me and I want a
big rock on my finger and all do you
think that a lot of times so you're
agree with that a lot of women are kind
of more for the party or the theatrics
of it over actually let me actually come
together with this man and I actually
love this guy and I want to be this guy
is it more of Life did you the party did
you ever see it on like Kevin Samuels
streams when the girls were engaged for
like two years and he's like why don't
you just go to the courthouse and get
married and then they're like oh no I
can't do that but when you think about
it the wedding's just one day a marriage
is the rest of your life like who gives
who cares about the wedding but do you
think they actually
were that complicated like in my head
and maybe this is wrong they it isn't
that they were thinking he is not
valuable after the wedding they haven't
even thought about after the wedding
they're just like you know they're all
like rainbows and unicorns about this
wedding and then afterwards they're like
should I have to roll over and look at
this guy for the next 50 years yeah and
that to me and maybe I want to always
see the best in people so maybe that's
uh no I agree with that when I was Nani
I could see by the pictures and but the
lifestyle they had before the marriage
and after the marriage and children and
some of that is like uh taking a list
I need it tick tick tick and once they
have they don't know what to do they are
not complete they are not happy some of
them some are really happy some of my
friends got married my sister she's
super happy but it's not all the cases
some of them is truly to show off
because I think relationship those days
became a goal if you can keep a
relationship you're already winning in a
society we're living
because it's super rare for you to keep
a relationship to have a good
relationship with your family is also a
challenge so a lot of people when they
have this relationship is all what the
people would say I think people really
care about you especially women sing
Single and a certain age they feel
insecure they feel afraid what people
will say and I think it's more what
people would say that what I'm feeling
because
well if they get married and divorced at
least they prove they were it's
desirable
to the divorce I fail as a woman I fail
as a mother it's it's really complicated
for you to assume when you when you fail
in something and in my opinion A
relationship is not failures it's about
working together or not I just think
like people need help like
narcissistic parents now all over on
Tick Tock a lot of victims came step in
and say how harsh they had to be growing
up a certain kind of parents
but yeah I think it's it's more about
you understand what you feel but not
caring about the outside it's really
difficult it's really difficult to be a
women and single people of course like
if you're married with the family people
or the respected Woman married with
Children so don't you don't you because
you just said it's hard to not think
about what the outside things right for
most of the people so so don't you think
that not having Instagram would be
beneficial for a marriage because then
you're not thinking as much about what
the outside thinks no 100 for me social
media which person would they have like
I work with that so I I had nowhere
Escape I work with this but for most of
people's option I I know a lot of guys
in London they have no Facebook no
Instagram at all I know a lot of people
who doesn't have any but you see why I
went earlier we're asking if you delete
your Instagram to a guy it's like if
you're willing to just get rid of it
easy it's it's better for the marriage
and a lot of times like girls think of
it as controlling but it's really just a
guy looking out for the relation
friendship in my opinion he is a bit
controlling because like especially in
Brazil like the clothes you're wearing
the boyfriends they want to tell you
what to do where to go who'd see but see
you you see it as controlling and I
think a lot of women do but guys are
looking at it as that like you're their
woman they want to protect you like we
look to them to protect and provide and
a lot of times they protect us from
ourselves because we might not look at a
certain outfit and think Hmm oh that's
like that's like gonna draw the wrong
attention to me but men know how other
men think I know I agree but like her
she's a dancer she is her job I work
with social media so to approach people
to be talking to people I need to be
online so I would say certain kinds of
jobs and certain it's not a question
it's like how much how much do you guys
like what you make thousands of dollars
from social media oh no no I work in the
corporate side I don't work with my page
as an influencer I'm not a new phone no
no so that's that's what I'm saying like
a lot of times like girls are so
attached to their social media and it's
like how much do you even really make
from it so for me it's more in my
network because well as a Public
Relation when you need to approach
someone like they didn't like seeing
what you're doing and I see I see what
you're saying but like my whole my whole
point is like you know that's not
something that you can't do with email
like I worked in Corporate America you
can you can use a LinkedIn and email
there's ways around it but it's just to
a guy when you're constantly questioning
his judgment it's just hard for him to
work with sorry to interrupt but in
terms of lack you see how she said
because I thoughts and stuff like even
when I'm going out like and you say your
thoughts I'll be like oh let me see your
Instagram let me see your work on
Instagram it's just like it's like it's
by force to kind of have it like they
see it as a portfolio like if that's
like your way of doing your job and how
you get your bookings and stuff that's
what I learned and I and I understand
that but I was just looking at your page
today I didn't I barely even saw those
new rules babe no but
there's rules in the main part and and
if it was marketed as like a strictly
dancing professional Pages our model as
well that's why like I I get booking
modeling and for dancing so there's
that's why it varies okay I I I don't
know your life but I know I know I'm
just I'm telling you how men would see
it
and you can you could say oh men won't
see it that way but we're in a room full
of men I you could ask them how they
would see it okay
after this we will definitely meet up
because let me just as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible